hey video lab members last week I
published a video on how we got the
explicit lyric sticker there were rock
record burnings across the country gene
Simmons from kiss said it best one time
he's like if you don't like my record he
was like go out and buy a thousand
copies of them and then burn it this is
a story that I've wanted to do for a
really really long time but I could
never find the right angle finally I
chose the rise of heavy metal and the
satanic panic because I felt like it was
very visually rich and super compelling
there's just so much archive out there
so much so that a lot of archive that I
found while researching the piece I
couldn't end up fitting in the video so
I figured I would share them with you
today so first I want to show you this
book that I got whenever I started doing
my research
it's called satanic panic pop culture
paranoia in the 1980s and the thing that
I love about it is that it has so much
interesting visual archive in it there's
one specific chapter on the rise of
heavy metal cult films one of them they
mention is called Trick or Treat trick
or treat
so trick-or-treat is a movie about this
teen who's basically haunted by a rock
star and there's references to
backmasking
rock and roll will never die at least
not this Halloween now my favorite part
about this movie is the fact that Ozzy
Osbourne makes an appearance and he
plays a televangelist who hates rock
music to the good old simple love song I
love you that's that's a good word shoes
nowadays they have to write some
sickness
it's just absolutely sick and bizarre
and I'm gonna do my utmost best to try
and stop it now
well I'm researching my stories I always
make playlists of songs that I come
across in my research or that I felt
feel like maybe might be good to
reference in the video those playlists
ultimately become way longer than
anything I could actually fit in a video
and so here's my little tiny PMRC
playlist of one of the songs is by Judas
Priest
it's called parental guidance here's a
clip from the music video
[Music]
so there's another song called Jesus he
knows me and it's by Genesis the Phil
Collins version of Genesis in the 1980s
a number of televangelists were sort of
marred by these scandals of their own
making and it sort of kind of portrayed
them as hypocrites they were telling
people to do certain things and then
they wouldn't do them themselves and
Phil Collins kind of gets at that that
dichotomy in this music video which is
just pure 1980s
[Music]
okay so there's two more left the next
one up is Frank Zappa on crossfire well
do look in the camera and tell whatever
any camera this is a clip that is 20
minutes long and I literally like wrote
my original pitch for this episode
around this moment we have to take a
break now we'll be back with John Lofton
Frank Zappa talking about rock music I
think the whole concept of a show like
CNN's crossfire is kind of basically
what you see today on CNN it's just a
bunch of people yelling at each other
it's not super effective but in this
episode in particular Frank Zappa pretty
much phones these guys left and right
some direction mr. Zappa Spanky here
come on woody troll you into that too no
I'm not into spanking I love it when
you're off like that
there's one particular soundbite about
10 minutes into the clip that kind of
distills this whole story down to just a
few words
oh you've told me several times how
about how about national defense this
national defense pal our families are
under attack from people like you with
these lyrics John you don't have to buy
them to make a statement about national
defense yeah the biggest threat to
America today is not communism it's
moving America toward a fascist
theocracy and everything that's happened
during the Reagan administration is
steering us right down that pipe yeah
well one example one example of a
fascist a opportunity when you have a
government that prefers a certain moral
code and derived from a certain religion
and that moral code turns into
legislation to suit what certain
religious point of view is absolutely
and if that code happens to be very very
right-wing almost toward Attila the Hun
well then you are an anarchist every
form of civil government is based on
some kind of morality Frank so we have
to talk about my favorite televangelist
brothers from the 1980s the Peters
brothers Ozzy Osbourne got his just dues
because as he was going through Lion
Country Safari a chimpanzee bit him
right on the face these guys are kind of
goofballs Prince try to stop her are you
kidding Prince tried to outdo or Twisted
Sister maybe didn't do that on stage but
I'll tell you he does some wild things
one of the brothers always feels like
he's
about to just break character and start
laughing at everything he's saying we
wanted to go from the rock that breaks
you to the rock that makes you and of
course that name of that rock is Jesus
Christ more seriously there a lot of
their clips are like really tone-deaf
and so I was trying to find moments and
like archival moments that sort of show
visual evidence of the fact that people
were really afraid of this sort of idea
that teen suicide was on the rise this
is a moment of the video that's kind of
sobering it's meant to be taken as
seriously as possible and I was trying
to find sort of archival evidence of
this either news clips or evangelists
talking about it and I came across the
Peters brothers clip
amidst affluence youth suicide has
spiraled more than doubling in the past
two decades explore some causes and
cures with your hosts the Peters
brothers van and Steven and it was so
tone deaf that I could not include it at
all here never yet reveal stories and
new insights in this investigative
report used suicide fantasy
the fact that they're talking about
something so serious
but there's like bouncy 80s music behind
it and then all of a sudden a very weird
twist
[Music]
like what it's so crazy yeah so that
about wraps it up thanks so much for
watching I really appreciate you all
subscribing to the video lab and I guess
I'll just say I'll see you next week
with a new episode of your were all
about disco